[Musique]
lorsque monsieur takieddine porte une
accusation sur un ancien chef de l'état
une enquête est immédiatement ouverte
lorsque le même individu sur la même
affaire porte une accusation sur un
magistrat la réponse du parquet national
financiers et circulez il n'ya rien à
voir
alors monsieur le premier ministre ma
question est simple est de vous comme
tant de français heurté et choqué par
cette réponse invraisemblable sur une
affaire d'une telle importance
ce ministre qui pour les uns nous disent
de sortir nous avons rien à faire dans
l'hémicycle et pour les autres nous
explique qu'il faut qu'on leur
soumettent les questions c'est
inacceptable c'est le gouvernement qui
est responsable devant parlement
monsieur le ministre vous n'êtes vous
êtes ici responsable devant nous et
c'est nous qui nous interrogeons et nous
at on dit merci monsieur lub la crise
sanitaire a eu pour conséquence vous le
savez la précarisation d'un million de
français
ce million est une estimation basse 800
mille pertes d'emplois sont attendues à
la fin de cette année comment rester
imperméable devant un drame pareil
les mois se suivent et apportent leur
lot de statistiques effrayantes l'aide
alimentaire est l'un des thermomètres
les plus frappants 8 millions de
personnes en france n'arrive plus à se
nourrir les associations constatent une
hausse de 25 % des demandes de l'aide
alimentaire une augmentation sans
précédent du nombre d'allocataires du
rsa du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi les
coiffeurs ne veulent plus couper les
cheveux en quatre
les restaurateurs souhaitent remettre le
couvert les libraires tourner la page
les fleury sont à fleur de peau pour
tous les commerçants et les indépendants
réouvrir est devenue une première
nécessité alors l'état protecteur où il
est à nous nous l'état providence et
souffle dans ses tentatives de colmater
les fissures d'une vie sous cloche
la liberté liberté chérie réclamer les
français ne supportent plus on leur
prête à penser
ils ont besoin d'espérer monsieur le
premier ministre
toutes les mesures d'accompagnement dans
notre économie sont les bienvenus mais
le plus important c'est l'ouverture de
nos commerces
ce n'est ni le digital ni le click and
collect qui va sauver le commerce de
proximité personnes
comprend plus rien les commerçants n'ont
aucune visibilité dans ces conditions
aucune perspective réelle pour cette
période de fin d'année et les fêtes de
noël on ne peut ajouter à la crise
sanitaire économique et sociale une
crise humaine qui pointent avec
désespoir de certains
nous avons saisi la semaine passée avec
45 collègues du groupe l'est républicain
la ministre déléguée au sport car la
règle d'une heure 1 km et l'interdiction
de toute pratique associative sans le
moindre discernement génère de graves
problèmes monsieur le ministre il ne
faut pas ajouter des absurdités aux
aberrations
quand on soulève des incohérences très
précises quand on fait des propositions
factuel ce n'est pas de la polémique
comme sur les commerces où vous finirez
par suivre nos propositions
chaque jour qui passe c'est du temps
perdu pour la santé des jeunes
générations test naso pharyngé sérologie
qui ont-ils génique ont démontré leur
intérêt mais aussi leurs limites en
termes de délais et de fiabilité
le laboratoire 6 de diag le cnrs et le
groupe snc skills elles ont développé
avec les médecins du chu de montpellier
un test salivaire appelé isikoff en
raison de la situation exceptionnelle à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés de
nombreux étudiants du monde de la santé
sont également mobilisés pour faire face
à la vague qui a submergé de nos
hôpitaux
si ces réquisitions sont indispensables
elle plonge les étudiants concernés dans
l'incertitude sur la suite donnée à leur
cursus
selon les régions les modalités de
suspension de ces formations sont en
effet variable cette prime
intitulé grand âge est de nature pérenne
elle vise à reconnaître l'engagement et
les compétences professionnelles des
aides-soignants et à motiver les
candidats en revalorisant leurs statuts
et leurs salaires madame la ministre les
remontées du terrain font pourtant
apparaître des inégalités de traitement
selon les structures dans lesquelles
travaillent les aides soignants vous
avez demandé la prolongation pour six
mois des aides à l'achat de voitures
neuves
à l'exception des voitures hybrides
diesel qui sont exclues du dispositif à
compter du 1er janvier 2021
les discours sur la réconciliation entre
industrie et écologie ne trompe personne
lorsqu'ils sont démenties par les faits
évidemment le diesel de seconde
génération doit prendre part à la
transition écologique mais par vos
mesures vous fait le choix inverse
une ferme l'hydroélectricité vertueuse
sur le plan environnemental inépuisable
d'une fiabilité d'une souplesse de
mobilisation inégale et concours en
outre à l'essor des territoires où elle
est implantée en permettant les multi
usages de l'eau en créant très tôt des
infrastructures haut de gamme
edf et la france ont vu beaucoup plus
loin que la plupart des autres pays
malgré tout depuis 2015 la commission
européenne met la france en demeure
d'ouvrir au champ concurrentiel
ces concessions hydroélectriques au fur
et à mesure qu'elles arrivent à échéance
par votre volonté de rester neutre quoi
qu'il en coûte
vous avez lâchement abandonné les
arméniens qui attendent des temps de
nous les laissant ainsi entre les mains
de poutine et erdogan dans les
motivations à peine voilée et
d'affaiblir en profondeur l'occident
pour l'un et d'anéantir nos valeurs pour
l'autre
[Musique]